what I but may have noticed you can also
import like I go to I'm at the point now
with Russia that I don't go to our
library I just import stuff that I
thought you can bring anything you want
in from any place you find it on the
internet and all of the functionality
that you saw saving the words and
phrases one thing you didn't see there
too is that those words those words and
phrases that are you can look at them as
flash cards in fact we even have an app
for the iPad where you can go through
your lessons and you can also go through
flashcards so there's a whole bunch of
stuff in there that helps you with
vocabulary and you can tag words and
phrases do a bunch of stuff that helps
you notice what's happened having a
writing corrected and when you have your
writing corrected then you get a
correction you're going to report with
all of your mistakes again highlighted
and replace with correct words and
phrases and then you import this and you
study that account similarly with your
conversations while you're talking to
your tutor the tutor will type any words
or phrases that you don't use correctly
you get that as a report you import that
and again you learn the words and
phrases from and you make friends so
what I feel is that the existing system
of education which is very expensive and
where the costs are going up when the
results are flat is largely one where
the student is dependent on the teacher
it's typically synchronous and has that
happened at the same time as teachers
there were kind of conditioned to
believe that that learning takes place
in the classroom whereas in fact
learning takes place in the brain
wherever the brain is it's all
standardized one-size-fits-all its
vertical it comes down to the teacher
and it's limited it might do what we're
heading towards and the ipod is a big
part of that ipad rather is it learning
to be independent from whatever age to
whatever age anytime anywhere reclining
at your couch at home customizable to
your interests horizontal your connect
not just in the classroom vertical with
the teacher and Hugh schoolmates but
wherever people of you know similar
interests maybe and so my mind that is
an unlimited learning opportunity and
I'll closed it this and that is that in
India they figure they can produce a
product similar to the ipad for
thirty-five dollars okay so the cost of
these things are going to go down the
speed of connectivity is going to go up
I mean I've had with the iphone they had
a thousand apps like two years ago
there's 200,000 apps now for the ipad
iphone ipad a lot of them are education
related they're not all good but the
good ones will survive so that when i
say the age of the ipad i think
education is very important like
economic well-being of individuals of
countries everything tracks to education
and so from that point of view I think
if the ipad is able to explode education
beyond the confines of our existing
system i think the impact on society
will be significant pretty much now i'm
open to counter arguments
guess what I see you haven't drawn
website yeah that was the one who showed
his talk I am I quite happy to hand out
name cards okay don't be bashful that
you it's Li ng cute we got mark ah
charge here's with it yes the majority
of people use a site free so that you
can access all of the content audio text
downloaded get on the farm during the
electric charge when you start saving
words and phrases to a database once you
reach 100 you then either delete in
order to create more space in other
words that limit is 100 once you're over
a hundred it costs a dollar so if you
don't want to spend ten dollars a month
let you keep the lead I mean we got
program first we have to pay 100 words
or phrase uttered units once you reach a
hundred that's the limit free so you
either some people just keep the leading
or you pick n dogz money and then it's
unlimited
the impression you know age and insert
or relation between our age and the
building louder growling it's not the
question I'm 65 yeah okay but you're
special fossil how many did you speak
before you even started this yeah I mean
absolutely yeah I'll tell you my date on
that and the research says that our
brains remain plastic for a long time
yes and then we're constantly renewing
I'm no neural scientist right but I read
a lot on a Sunday with that and I select
those things that are favorable to my
argument and ignore the others but it
does say that our brain remains plastic
and that we're constantly renewing
renewing cells or neurons or whatever so
I believe that it's motivation it's time
and its attendant regardless of the age
I know in my own case that I'm a better
Lana Turner today than I was when I was
16 when I was 16 I had rented school and
I kind of could put a few words together
wasn't very interested ran into a
professor Miguel who totally turned me
on to learn French and so I always said
greatest function of professor can or a
teacher can perform is to turn on the
learner and but and this is my son mark
it just come back from an overseas trip
so he saw another pleasure plus he had a
kids hockey practice or either code so
yeah I mean you hear these things that
all people you know I get that up to the
age about five young people like chill
infants have a big advantage because
they haven't yet kind of coagulated
around one language and my understanding
is the brain is a bit of a Darwinist
Darwinian types
so that your language is not taking over
so the first new language you're
learning it's difficult to get it in
there then and because I've earned a lot
of language it becomes easier and easier
for me because I'm not so fixed on my
own but I think that's the situation so
whether if you're a unilingual person at
age 20 40 60 80 I don't think it makes
difference yep is it more difficult to
acquire a comprehensible comprehensible
pronunciation older we get yeah before
puberty new speaker accent but
absolutely figure on Cantonese after 50s
well I took on Mike again I'm not
difficult because but then I I did you
know I would like France and then
subsequently went to Congress lady
Chinese and but I've seen people you
know at age 20 go to Japan China and
they speak very very well and those are
languages that are significantly
different some people do better than
others my own view is that I don't think
it's a realistic goal to speak like a
native I don't think that's a realistic
goal however well you speak the language
if you can make yourself understood
you're doing fine and I think that it's
far more important to have good phrasing
and good vocabulary and we know
ourselves if we come across a non-native
who seems to have very good
pronunciation but doesn't understand
what we're saying really can't express
themselves very well I remember I had
this Swiss banker and he came to visit
us with this psychic who was English and
the Swiss banker had that him his to his
sex implicit but he spoke in a far
better than the image and I think the
issue is words and phrases and control
the money and yet some people are going
to be better at selling like a native
knowledge but I don't think sounding
like a native is a realistic goal
carnet stay here race couple great
interest in points there one